GABRIELA FERRARA: Welcome.
In this session, watch as
we deploy an application
of the utmost importance
and mission critical value,
a meme generator.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Memes are serious business, so
we use for our stack Cloud SQL
and Kubernetes to guarantee the
availability and scalability
of our application.
Just so you have an
idea, everything Google
runs within containers.
Did you know we deploy around
4 billion containers per week?
It's impressive number.
To achieve such scale, we needed
a reliable tool, Kubernetes.
It was developed not to only
solve Google's infrastructure
challenges, but also to be
accessible to developers.
With its declarative
set of APIs,
Kubernetes can run on GKE,
Google Kubernetes Engine,
or even on a multi-cloud
environment outside
of the Google Cloud Platform--
all of that with auto-repair,
auto-upgrade, and auto-scale.
Cloud SQL is our
persistent database
used to store the generating
memes created by users,
and it is set up to
have high availability
across different zones.
But deploying is not the
only objective at hand.
Watch as we delete
nodes and force
a failover in the database.
After all, outages can
happen, and you wouldn't
want to miss anything, right?
How about trying by yourself
the deployment and force
a failover?
You can also take
this opportunity
to have some fun with memes.
Check out the full talk to
see the deployment steps
for this application in action.
And don't forget, subscribe
to our channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]